Thanks to the release of The Suicide Squad,
the villain known as Bloodsport has taken
center stage in the DCEU. But
just who is this rampaging rascal,
and why is he such a big deal in the world of
comics? This is the untold truth of Bloodsport.
"We're all gonna die."
"I hope so."
"Oh, for God's sake."
The original Bloodsport is Robert DuBois, a madman
who kills dozens of innocent Metropolis citizens
during a rampage that unfolds in Superman Vol. 2
#4. DuBois commands a seemingly endless arsenal
of high-tech weaponry that he can teleport
into his grasp, including a pistol that
fires slivers of Kryptonite. He is portrayed
as a perpetually-enraged Vietnam War veteran,
often yelling at his victims that they're
wasting the freedom he fought to preserve.
After Bloodsport's initial attack on a restaurant,
in which he massacres over two dozen civilians,
Superman gets involved and corners DuBois in a
bowling alley. Bloodsport wounds Superman with
a Kryptonite bullet, but thankfully, Jimmy
Olsen's timely intervention saves Kal-El
from certain death. In the meantime, the fact
that Bloodsport has access to Kryptonite leads
Superman to correctly deduce that DuBois'
sponsor is none other than Lex Luthor.
It's Jimmy Olsen who figures out the key to
defeating Bloodsport, when his research leads him
to the discovery that the villain never actually
served in Vietnam. When his number came up,
he fled to Canada, and his younger brother Mickey
went to Vietnam in his place, losing his arms and
legs for his trouble. DuBois' guilt drove him
mad and turned him into Bloodsport. Jimmy finds
Mickey and brings him to the battle, where he
pleads with Bloodsport to stop his rampage.
Bloodsport collapses in tears at the sight of
his brother, and the gunman is sent to a maximum
security psychiatric facility. Of course, that's
not the last of Bloodsport — not by a long shot…
Adventures of Superman #507 opens with a heavily
armed masked man, who calls himself Bloodsport,
interrupting a mugging in a Metropolis
alleyway. As he kills two of the three muggers,
you may believe he's a crime-fighter with less
forgiving tactics, similar to Marvel's Punisher.
But when he cuts down the victim of the mugging
too, things start to become a little clearer.
This is Alex Trent — a white supremacist dedicated
to killing as many people of color as he can.
The story bleeds into Action Comics
#694, and over the course of both issues,
the new Bloodsport kills even more innocents
than his predecessor — mostly people of color,
though he's also happy to turn his violent
attentions to whites he despises for
consorting with other races. With the
arrival of the cyborg villain Hi-Tech,
it's revealed that both she and Bloodsport
are pawns of the demon Bloodthirst.
Bloodsport is presumed dead following an explosion
at the end of Action Comics #694, but the
following year, in Action Comics #702, he returns
to continue his racist rampage. Just as Jimmy
Olsen is key to defeating the original Bloodsport,
it's another Daily Planet employee — reporter Ron
Troupe — who locates Trent's Achilles' heel. Like
DuBois before him, Trent teleports his weapons to
his hands, though his teleporter is implanted in
his chest so no one can take it from him. However,
Troupe tracks down Bloodsport's weapons cache
and destroys it, leaving nothing for the racist
to fight with. Superman captures Trent, who is
subsequently sent to Stryker's Island Prison.
In 1995's Adventures of Superman #526,
Robert DuBois falls victim to the most
devastating villain of all: budget cuts.
Needing to siphon off some of its patients,
the psychiatric facility where DuBois is being
treated has transferred him to Stryker's Island
Prison — the same prison Alex Trent was
sent to after his latest series of killings.
DuBois and Trent are destined to collide,
and things don't go well for either of them.
Hoping to ease tensions in his prison,
the Stryker's Island warden agrees to a
boxing match between the two Bloodsports,
with the proviso that Superman act as referee. The
Man of Steel agrees, though he accurately deduces
that allowing the boxing match probably
isn't a great idea in the first place.
The match itself doesn't last very long. DuBois
easily dominates Trent in its early stages,
after which Trent tackles his opponent to the
ground. But when Superman pulls the boxers apart,
Trent reveals a gun. As it turns out,
his Aryan Brotherhood allies have managed
to get him a new cache of weapons. A riot
quickly erupts, and Superman must struggle
to control the rampaging prisoners while
trying to get a hold of DuBois and Trent.
DuBois manages to get Trent's gun from him
and even escapes past the walls of the prison,
but he's quickly gunned down
and killed by the guards. Trent
survives the riot… but not for long. His
Aryan Brotherhood buddies learn that,
at one point during the chaos, Superman
had to save Trent from DuBois. Ashamed
that a Black man got the better of Trent, the
Brotherhood burns Trent to death in his cell.
The third version of Bloodsport to appear in
the comics has so far proven to be the most
mysterious. Unlike the late
Robert DuBois and Alex Trent,
he doesn't make any claim about twisted
ideals serving as his inspiration,
and like many supervillains, he seems to don
his red skullcap mask purely for the money.
During the late 2000s, Bloodsport appears as
one of five villains hired to kill the Man of
Steel by the criminal organization Intergang
— the others being Riot, Silver Banshee,
Livewire, and Hellgrammite. This story
is part of DC's "One Year Later" event,
in which Superman's powers are just beginning
to return after a battle with Superboy Prime.
Superman's narration indicates that
this Bloodsport's techniques are at
least a little different from those of
his predecessors, and suggests that the
teleportation he uses to retrieve his
weapons is "extradimensional" in nature.
In spite of his weakened state, Superman is
eventually able to defeat the five villains.
This new Bloodsport's name is never revealed,
but it's clear he's more of a mercenary than
the villains who previously took the name.
He expresses excitement at the money offered
for Superman's life, particularly after some of
his comrades have been defeated and he realizes
he could get a bigger piece of the pie. This
Bloodsport's given name has yet to be revealed,
and since "One Year Later," most of his
appearances have come in the form of cameos.
Bloodsport made his mark on the DC
Animated Universe in the mid-2000s,
though in a relatively minor role. In
2005, he made his first appearance on
Justice League Unlimited in season 2's "The Cat
and the Canary." The episode revolves around
a meta-brawl run by the entrepreneurial
villain Roulette. In this epic showdown,
supervillains and heroes fight for sport
— some of them against their will. Here,
Bloodsport is introduced briefly as he's locking
horns with the Batman bad guy Electrocutioner.
It isn't clear whether or not Bloodsport
survives the events of Justice League Unlimited,
though it seems unlikely. While he's usually
only seen in the background, Bloodsport is a
member of the Legion of Doom in the series. But
when the Legion of Doom's spaceship is destroyed
by Darkseid in the show's penultimate episode, it
isn't revealed whether or not Bloodsport survives.
His death is implied, however, as he isn't one of
the villains saved by Star Sapphire and Sinestro.
It's never really made clear exactly who
this version of Bloodsport is supposed
to be. His given name isn't revealed, and
the unnamed version of Bloodsport had yet
to appear in DC's comics at the time the
series was produced. For the time being,
this has to be chalked up as yet
another unsolved Bloodsport mystery.
Before Idris Elba took the role in The Suicide
Squad, David St. Louis played Robert DuBois in
the season 3 premiere of CW's Supergirl.
However, while he shares DuBois' name,
there are significant differences between this
Bloodsport and the villain from the source
material. Instead of covering up his draft-dodging
like the original Bloodsport, Supergirl's version
does have a military background — which proves
invaluable in his job as a terrorist-for-hire.
"Meet Robert DuBois. Goes
by the name of Bloodsport,
which is not any sport I've ever heard of."
Bloodsport first locks horns with Supergirl
in the cold open of "Girl of Steel," when she
joins the National City Police in pursuit of
DuBois and his goons. While he doesn't appear
to have any metahuman abilities, Bloodsport
is clearly close to peak human condition,
as he not only survives getting knocked a hundred
yards through the air by Supergirl and crashing
onto the roof of a parked car, but he's even able
to brush himself off and escape moments later.
It's later revealed that Bloodsport is working
for the crooked businessman Morgan Edge. At Edge's
behest, Bloodsport steals some captured alien
technology, then uses it to cloak a submarine and
attack the city's waterfront. Inevitably, however,
he's quickly defeated by Supergirl and arrested.
Robert DuBois' time in the afterlife
comes to an end in 2021's Suicide
Squad #5. The issue opens with
a quick recap of DuBois' origin,
though there's no mention of his death
in 1995's Adventures of Superman #526.
With all the various reboots and re-workings
DC's continuity has undergone since 1995,
it can probably be assumed either that DuBois
was resurrected by undisclosed means in the
intervening years, or that his death at Stryker's
Island Prison has been erased from history.
Bloodsport's role in the Suicide Squad is
more specific than the rest of Task Force X.
Amanda Waller sends him through
a number of different dimensions,
gathering intel and recruiting new captives
for Waller to use. To help him, Waller arms
DuBois with a new suit and helmet to protect
him from the strains of interdimensional travel,
as well as a nearly unlimited arsenal of weapons
that he can teleport to himself across dimensions.
While a flashback montage early in Suicide Squad
#5 suggests that Bloodsport has
been going it solo for a while,
he probably won't be able to manage on his
own for long. The issue finds him in Earth-3,
the home of the Crime Syndicate — a group of
super crooks made up of sadistic versions of the
Justice League heroes. By the end of the issue,
Bloodsport is captured by Ultraman, Earth-3's
brutish answer to Superman, forcing Waller to
send in a new team to bring Bloodsport home.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.